the current craze of transgenderism
is precisely that is a craze
the spread of queerness
shows no signs of slowing down not just
in terms of numbers but in terms of
letters too
the the lgbt
lmnop initialism seems to gain
a letter every four hours or so
very likely by the end of this dinner
tonight there will be a new letter at
least one added to the initialism
today i'm this is not a joke the
initialism is
lgbtqip
2saa plus
don't forget the plus there's a lot more
to have a few years ago
a lot of people made fun of facebook
because facebook
added 54 genders to the choice of gender
it was 56 total and we all made fun of
that
today
a medical website lists the number of
genders at 74.
it's grown
it's grown and grown and it's going to
keep growing
i was recently scrolling through libs of
tick-tock which is something that i try
to do in my spare time try to make sense
of it all
and i came across a video of two young
women who were dressed up in all sorts
of rainbow colors and clothing and they
were trying to explain what their sexual
identities are and how they came to
acquire them
here is what one girl said i am quoting
verbatim
she said i'm gay
i think at like 10 i knew i was gay but
i wasn't clear on my gender it was
around then when i started questioning
if i was bi
and since then it was kind of a slippery
slope because then i was like am i bi
omni
lesbian
and then i got to the point recently
where i was like am i pan
but i think now i'm starting to realize
that i'm queer but yeah i am gender
queer trans mask and queer
the trans mask through me too so i
looked that up trans mask she explained
quote is like people under the
non-binary umbrella identifying as or
presenting mask
doesn't clear it up really but it's an
explanation then the girl next to her
said quote
i'm trans and my sexuality is unlabeled
i use he him pronouns and not missing a
beat the first girl replied and i use he
they pronouns
they
our name is legion for we are many is i
suppose the only
only place i would hear that kind of a
pronoun i don't know
[Applause]
so i was very puzzled i had lots of
questions as a result of this exchange
lots and lots of questions but one
question stood out among the others
have these young women
ever in their lives even for one
solitary second
thought about someone or something other
than themselves
ever even once
there are so many interesting things in
the world
birds
bumblebees
music algebra the beach buffalo wild
wings there's a whole lot of stuff in
this world
there is there are there are so many
things in this world that can inspire us
that can lift our eyes up in in wonder
and awe
is there really nothing on earth that
interests these people other than
themselves
for years conservatives have talked
until we're blue in the face about the
inconsistencies of gender ideology
it's biological absurdity it's
metaphysical incoherence we talk about
it all the time
i think we have failed to identify and
appreciate
that what is perhaps the essential
feature of gender ideology
namely the narcissism that suffuses the
entire movement the whole thing is just
people talking endlessly about
themselves
i am now convinced that every gender
identity other than man and woman and
boy and girl is really just a synonym
for narcissist
and by narcissism by the way i don't
just mean that these people are selfish
everybody is selfish
some more
some less we can try to reign it in
but we are all selfish to a certain
degree
by narcissism i mean something more
pernicious
not merely the obsession with self
but with
the need for constant affirmation the
need for others to validate one's
self-esteem
i mean in the words of christopher lash
the historian and social critic a quote
dependence on the vicarious warmth
provided by others combined with a fear
of dependence a sense of inner emptiness
boundless repressed rage
i'm not pointing fingers at anybody or
placing blame on anyone for falling prey
to narcissism
we live in a particularly narcissistic
age christopher lash saw this happening
in 1979 in his book the culture of
narcissism
in a narcissistic society lash wrote a
society that gives increasing prominence
and encouragement to narcissistic traits
the cultural devaluation of the past
reflects not only the poverty of the
prevailing ideologies which have lost
their grip on reality and abandoned the
attempt to master it but the poverty of
the narcissist's inner life
three major traits the devaluation of
the past the poverty of the ideologies
and the emptiness of people's inner
lives
as far as i can tell we are three for
three at the moment i think he is
describing our world even more so than
he was describing his own
the unholy jihad in recent years against
everyone and everything that came before
us has kicked into particularly high
gear
the statue topplers are going after any
everyone they're not just going after
those pesky confederates they're going
after everyone they're going after teddy
roosevelt they're going after lincoln in
some cases they're going after ulysses
grant
george washington university did you see
this george washington university in
washington dc
just cancelled its mascot
george washington the colonial
washington got canceled
everyone has to go
it is not just the distant past that we
have discarded
today if you express the view of
marriage that barack obama and joe biden
and every other prominent politician in
the country held in 2011
you will be mocked scolded or worse as
some sort of irrational fringe bigot
in place of an argument people will just
cite the current year
they'll say you how do you believe that
you must be crazy you can't say such a
thing it's 2022.
as though the number of times we spin
around the sun determines the difference
between truth and falsehood
this is ironically the very height of
bigotry the rejection
of everything that everyone has ever
said or done or believed simply because
we weren't around when they said or did
or believed it
an unshakable confidence in our own
rightness and perfection and similarly
an unshakable confidence in the idiocy
and wickedness of everyone who came
before us it is an expression of
narcissism
now you might think that this hatred of
the past that's taken over our culture
in recent years
stems from some supreme confidence in
the future i don't think so